this season very much feels like it
could be the end or the beginning of the
end for Joe's story
how much more of Joe's story do you
think there is to tell Beyond season
four I would think that
this is like a
if we don't get another season this
could this could
be a a somewhat satisfying end but I
think to really bring it home I mean Joe
at this point he's uh he's like a
post-modern icon of some kind you know
and I mean he's something he's
definitely the fact that he's such a
popular dude
um it's something right you know so like
there's there's gotta be a to me a a
more thorough and satisfying conclusion
I have so many tools no sure killing is
one of many but it's certainly not a
one-size-fits-all solution
she's here to change the world
killing Parts also much easier now
that I'm honest with myself about it I'm
just here to help what is your message
to the fans after they finished part two
they've seen where Joe is are you okay
how do you feel do you need some time
don't binge it again right now just yet
don't do it that's my message Joe winds
up where it all began is this a fresh
start for him like what does Joe back in
New York if you could dream up where he
goes well clearly he's back home in New
York
thank God by the way because I don't
have to move again I've had to move
every season that's exhausting
um
but now he's got sort of unlimited
resources he actually has the sort of
power he's not had you know with love
and the Quinn family he had power but he
didn't want it he didn't want to take it
he didn't want it the family didn't
really want to give it to him you know
so
I think now he's embracing
really his lower nature he's he's
letting the animal take over the human
basically he's letting the Predator take
over the whatever the yeah his heart and
he's
um probably gonna be
just quite unhinged oh I guess I don't
know though
yeah I really don't know and there's at
least two people out in the world now
who kind of know everything about you
that's true that's true and one of them
is in prison and one of them is in
hiding
so it could be a Revenge season there's
a lot of options that's true yeah yeah I
mean honestly it's a question for the
writers now I will say that Greg
berlanti pitched me on on an end that I
thought was brilliant I can't tell you
what it is was that like when you signed
on for the show or something no no he
pitched it to me like a year and a half
ago like before we before I knew it was
happening in season four he also told me
how he thought it would end in season
five and I thought yeah that's that's
great okay every season has centered
around a love story
if you had died I would never have
forgiven you
do you think Kate is Joe's end game
I think he's the I think I think she's
the last
meaningful relationship he'll be in
yeah because I don't think there's
another one coming down the pike
I think she's gonna be yeah I think
she's his end game end game does that
mean
like they're together together forever
well no I don't think that no I don't no
that relationship's not gonna last but
it's the last for Joe I think I think I
mean literally that's not even a spoiler
I just I don't know uh we do get the
blast from the past this season don't
look at me it's your dream
what did you do this time
hi Joe what was it like to reunite with
them for those little moments it was
nice I mean I was also directing that
episode so it was very it was it was
poignant it was really lovely to have
them back they're both you icons you
know so I really appreciated being able
to direct them as well what's the
challenge in directing yourself
um time more than anything time because
you're in front of the camera you can't
be behind it it is uh it is it is a
phenomenal challenge but I did love it
foreign